hello internet how are you doing well I
hope great awesome that is fantastic to
hear grace here I'm grace I'm the only
one that could possibly be here right
now
last weekend I talked to you about
possibly doing Saturday sessions which
was a day that I spent quacking a story
to you and I quickly did not live up to
that idea because I did not record
anything this Saturday what a letdown
I am the parent that you grow to hate
because they keep making empty promises
no wonder kids end up murdering their
parents who are terrible - what am i -
anyway here's a little story for you so
today I tweeted I'm not totally sure but
I think I might have unintentionally
raised a Guido dude in the park while
running it all happened so fast
and that's true here's the thing I live
across the street from a park which is
awesome and so I try to exercise every
now and then by utilizing the park while
the weather is nice and going for runs
but the problem is a lot of people like
to utilize the park and I don't fault
them for that it's a great park to
utilize but when you're running all
within the same loop of each other you
have to sort of be conscious about the
speed that you're running out so that
you don't stay next to one stranger the
whole time you want to always sort of
either be passing people or having
people pass you it's never fun to like
hang with a stranger because honestly
when I'm running I am my worst possible
self I breathe heavy and disgusting I
run with my body all over the place so
today I'm running and I noticed that
this bigger tribal tattoo football asked
Italian possibly ish guy and he passed
me I was fine but he didn't pass me with
a speed that kept him in front of me
the whole time or like pushed him
further in front of me so I ended up
just kind of like running like 10-15
feet behind him the whole time which was
really bizarre and so at the end of my
run I like to as they say kick it into
high gear so I always try and sprint out
the last you know I don't know 15 20 30
seconds of my run so I'm still 10 15
feet behind this guy and so I move over
to the other side of the road and as I
start sprinting I realized he's now
sprinting and we are maybe 20 or 30 feet
horizontally apart from each other both
sprinting as fast as we can we're
neck-and-neck to the point where it has
become clear that we're racing each
other we're two adults and we're now
racing each other in a park filled with
children and so I I don't slow down
because I all of a sudden I get very
hyped up and so I start running as fast
as I can and then finally he stopped
because I guess that was the end of his
run and I kept going because I still had
a little bit further but it was one of
those moments where you're silently in
tune with what's happening with someone
and it keeps happening and then you
break off and it's done and then I
finished shortly after that and I walked
to my apartment and I had never felt
more confused after a run or strange I
raced a grown man in the park today by
accident I think